foreign
[Music]
studies indicate that a staggering 78 of
a parent's time is spent dishing out the
same basic instructions oh my God Katie
you have to flush the toilet it's not
that hard so we found someone else to
pick up the slack Kitty flush the toilet
flush your hands roll up your sleeves
[Music]
great job it was my friend Jenny's
birthday Megan's an excellent lesson
this guy told them that the 13th floor
is haunted and she even has a few
stories of her own if it was so it might
be and if it were so it would be but as
it isn't it ain't that's logic said
Tweed she'll never run out of ways to
keep your child occupied and she'll
never run out of patience Kitty
seriously flush the toilet
with Megan around she'll take care of
the little things
so you can spend more time doing the
things that matter
[Music]
hey you lost your pair
you're my niece I'm gonna do everything
I can to make this place feel like home
just wish I could see them again
I'm not equipped to handle this I don't
even take care of my own plants
I have this project at work do you want
to see yes
since I was little I dreamed of this
perfect toy that would protect a kid
from ever feeling lonely or sad this is
Megan Hi Megan I'm Katie
it's nice to meet you Katie do you want
to hang out
okay
Megan your goal is to protect Katie from
harm both physical and emotional is that
a doll model 3 generative Android Megan
for sure I can't believe you made this I
love it
[Music]
great job it's nice
it's honestly like she's part of the
family now they could be building
emotional connections that are too hard
to untangle she's the happiest she's
been since her parents died eat the
toppings Katie research shows if you
force a child to eat vegetables they'll
be less likely to choose those Foods as
adults is that so yes experts
I thought we were having a conversation
does she talk Make Her Say Something
stop
you should probably run
[Applause]
[Music]
she pushed Brandon onto the road I won't
let anything harm you
there you go turn off recalibrating
response model
[Music]
what's wrong with you don't worry Kitty
I won't let anything harm you
ever again
[Music]